[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zu einer spezialausgabe von
filtern 85 köpfe fünf meinungen seit 13
tagen wird putins furchtbarer kriegt
unsere außenministerin an in der berg
hat heute hier im studio gesagt zitat
putin ist derzeit offenbar nicht zu
stoppen weil er jeglichen menschlichen
grenzen überschreitet ein statement das
angst macht und die frage aufwirft wie
schaffen wir es putins die ernsthaften
verhandlungen zu bewegen darüber möchte
ich heute abend mit meinen gästen
debattiert bild chefredakteur und tv
chef claus strunz der frühere chef der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz wolfgang
ischinger er stellvertretender
chefredakteur und für den nach acht
große hans hammer der uns wie jeden
abend live aus kiew zugeschaltet ist und
last but not least moderatorin und
unternehmerin leute würdig eröffnen
möchte ich die runde gerne wie jeden
abend den eindrücken von paul ronzheimer
paul annalena baerbock heute hier bei
bild im gespräch mit bild chef johannes
boje und der kanadischen außenministerin
melanie juli gesagt wir sehen ganz klar
dass sie ein mann koste es was es wolle
ein anderes land zerstören will gibt es
für dich ein szenario wie dieser krieg
doch noch zugunsten der ukraine ausgehen
könnte
janina schönen guten abend hier aus kiew
tatsächlich ist es mal für ein paar
stunden ruhiger in dieser stadt in der
wir so viele sie reden so viele bomben
so viel artillerie gehört haben in den
vergangenen tagen und das macht
zumindest vom gefühl her etwas hoffnung
hoffnung darauf das ist vielleicht doch
noch eine irgendwie geartete
diplomatische lösung geben könnte ich
will euch mal beschreiben wie das
aussieht in kiel gibt es nicht nur eine
frontlinie sondern natürlich auch
diplomatische gespräche politiker
treffen sich an geheimen orten in
atombunker sie wechseln die orte um
darüber zu sprechen wie die zukunft
einer ukraine aussehen könnte das sind
alles geheimgespräche ich habe versucht
mit verschiedenen quellen heute darüber
zu sprechen welche szenarien welche
auswege ist aus dieser krise geben
könnte der erste das wäre tatsächlich
eine aufgabe der ukraine also odyssee
lenski würde in den nächsten tagen zu
dem schluss kommen dass die militärische
übermacht russlands egal wie heldenhaft
sich die ukrainische soldaten
verteidigen zu groß ist tatsächlich gibt
es hinweise darauf dass immer weiteres
militär insbesondere hier richtung kiew
gebracht wird das schwereres gerät in
richtung der hauptstadt kommt und dass
das dann bedeuten könnte dass es
tausende zehntausende möglicherweise
hunderttausende tote geben könnte
dennoch könnte sie lenski wenn er in den
nächsten tagen verhandelt versuchen den
preis nach oben zu drücken den preis der
aufgabe das würde bedeuten er müsste
darüber sprechen was mit dem osten
passiert wäre das wirklich eine
komplette unabhängigkeit was passiert
mit diesen gebieten dann müsste er über
die krim sprechen wladimir putin will
dass die krim akzeptiert wird als
russisch und er müsste über eine
demilitarisierung sprechen das problem
für seal entgegen dem fall wie mir viele
berater und regierungsvertreter gesagt
haben ist dass er glaubt dass viele
glauben dass das in der bevölkerung
insbesondere momentan nicht durchsetzbar
ist weil die bevölkerung so geschlossen
steht und so patriotisch steht dass
viele sagen wir wollen uns unser land
nicht nehmen lassen die zweite option
diese lenski oder die das land hat das
wäre tatsächlich deckt weitere krieg der
kampf da sagen diejenigen die diese
option befürworten unser militär ist
viel besser als gedacht wir erleben ein
riesiges chaos in der russischen armee
wie erleben dass ein general bereits
umgekommen ist wir leben auch durch den
druck der waffen durch die druck der
waffenlieferung aus dem westen dass wir
russland aufhalten können bei diesem
szenario geht es nicht darum dass man
glaubt dass man das ende diese schlacht
so muss man es nennen gewinnen kann
sondern es geht darum zeit zu gewinnen
druck auszuüben und dafür zu sorgen dass
putin zu hause weiter unter druck gerät
diejenigen die dieses szenario
befürworten sagen das erste szenario
können wir nicht machen weil putin dann
gewonnen hätte weil putin dann
weitergeht was tut sie nicht aufhören
würde wenn wir das erste szenario machen
und uns sozusagen mehr oder weniger
ergeben dann wäre das ganze erst der
anfang und wir kämpfen hier für ganz
europa das sind die beiden szenarien die
theoretisch möglich sind über die hier
in kiew heftig diskutiert wird in
geheimgesprächen in geheimen atom
bunkern und natürlich insbesondere mit
blöde mütze
lenzing mit blick auf ihre diplomatische
erfahrung auch als früherer chef der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz würde ich
sie gerne fragen welches szenario ist
denn denkbar oder gibt es noch ein
anderes szenario wo sie sagen so können
der krieg enden
ich denke zurzeit ist auch nach dem was
wir gerade von fall runter gehört haben
der ausgang die entwicklung in den
kommenden tagen und wochen völlig unklar
es kann sein dass die ukrainischen
kräfte sich so lange halten können dass
tatsächlich
nicht nur essentiell lenski gezwungen
ist über kompromissformel nachzudenken
sondern das umgekehrt auch die russische
führung impfungen sein wird über
reduzierungen ihrer bisherigen
maximalforderungen nachzudenken und und
das etwas zu sagen wer wahl zu
deeskalieren aber dass sie mich dazu
folgendes sagen das geht alles nur wenn
wir die gesprächskanäle wenn wir spricht
die usa gegenüber der russischen
föderation wir die bundesrepublik
deutschland die bundesregierung
gegenüber der russischen regierung und
andere
beteiligten mächte und organisation wenn
wir die gesprächskanäle nach moskau
offen halten es ist wichtig dass der
amerikanische generalstabschef mit
seinem russischen kollegen redet um
missverständnisse und fehleinschätzungen
zu verhindern niemandem in der ukraine
ist gedient wenn dieser konflikt egal
aus welchem grund plötzlich jenseits der
ukraine eskaliert das ist doch für uns
die entscheidende aufgabe wie können wir
dafür sorgen dass dies nicht zu einem
raschen sieg dieses und aalen russischen
vorgehens führt aber gleichzeitig
verhindern dass das zu einem
europäischen oder globalen flächenbrand
dass die entscheidende diplomatische
aufgabe wie der ausgang sein wird kann
ich im augen er sagen aber ich bin
bester meinen wir müssen mit der
russischen regierung selbst
wenn es uns wütend macht selbst wenn es
massive kritik wir müssen diese
gesprächskanäle offen halten denn mit
wem wollt ihr denn fallen mit wem soll
serie denn verhandeln wenn dich mit
denen die in moskau im augenblick die
inhaber der macht sind
die gesprächskanäle noch offen oder ist
es schon eigentlich 14 deeskaliert naja
als erstmal hoffe ich dass alle hören
was wolfgang ischinger einfordert weil
das ja was mit klugheit und besonnenheit
zu tun hat und in einem so emotionalen
auch von bildern getriebenen konflikt wo
menschen sozusagen bei laufender kamera
in die luft gepumpt werden wo eine
eskalation der des krieges der worte zu
verzeichnen waren letzte woche ist es
keineswegs selbstverständlich also
insofern hoffentlich bleibt dieser
diplomatische kanal offene es essentiell
ich glaube auch dass man mit den
vokabeln
gewinnen und verlieren sieg und
niederlage wird lernen müssen neue
umzugehen also was gibt es für die
ukraine noch zu gewinnen stell dich mal
als frage also dass es so bleibt wie es
vorher war ist ein unerreichbares ziel
angesichts der dominanz von putin auf
putins seite sieht es anders aus putin
hat das gefühl gewinnen können in den
letzten tagen und wochen auch wenn er
sich die rede von oder das interview von
annalena baerbock heute transkribieren
lässt von seinem botschafter dass er den
westen da hat wo er ihn haben will also
wir stehen geschlossen zueinander wir
setzen auf sanktionen die sanktionen
sind so mittel hart wird die härte den
härtegrad der sanktionen gibt es viele
debatten
wir hängen es sozusagen wir sitzen in
der falle der abhängigkeit das alles
wird putin er vorher antizipiert haben
und deshalb ist er derjenige der auch
auf dem diplomatischen parkett im moment
die stärkere position hat also mein bild
dafür wäre wenn es bin gespannt ob der
woche ist das teilen würde würden wir
das auf einem schachbrett sehen und ich
darf mal ganz kurz daran erinnern dass
schach im prinzip ein kriegsspiel ist
wenn wir es auf einem schachbrett sehen
hält putin nicht nur die ukraine sondern
den westen im moment im schach und wir
sagen aber wir haben ihm aber an bauern
wird geschlagen mit unseren sanktionen
und das macht mir schon sorge dass nicht
nur die militärische auseinandersetzung
asynchron ist sondern auch die
diplomatische da sitzt ein starker
herrscher am tisch ein diktator ein
mensch der auf menschenrechte nicht
besonders viel wert legt und da sitzen
die führer die anführer einer westlichen
wertegemeinschaft mit am tisch die immer
zum glück die westlichen werte
hochhalten dadurch aber am tisch
schwächer wirken müssen und das finde
ich im diplomatischen
aus diplomatischen auseinandersetzung in
eine situation die zusage erfüllt weil
man an dunkel wie das ausgeht wenn man
aus dem lachen nicht mehr heraus kommt
schon leute wolfgang ischinger klar
strom zu werben ja dafür für die
diplomatie und für das gespräch wenn du
auch als bürgerin die diese bilder
ansieht verstehst du dann auch dass
viele auch in der debatte von emotionen
überschwemmt sind und eigentlich nur
noch fordern noch härtere sanktion noch
mehr militär ja natürlich die bilder die
wir tagtäglich sehen mit dem
konfrontiert werden die sind schrecklich
und man kann sich das nicht vorstellen
dass es so etwas heutzutage noch gibt
und das zerreißt einem das herz wenn man
das sieht und natürlich kann man
verstehen dass es viele jetzt gibt die
emotional am liebsten handeln würden und
aber klar natürlich schließlich auch dem
dann in dem moment an das bringt uns
natürlich nur kurzfristig weiter
langfristig gesehen wäre es natürlich
toll wenn man sich an einen tisch setzen
könnte und das ganze aus diskutieren
könnte besprechen könnte verhandeln
könnte aber wir reden halt hier nicht
über vernünftige erwachsene menschen
sondern über putin und ich glaube putin
wird das so weiter machen bis er selbst
mal getroffen wird und damit meine ich
jetzt nicht mit militärischer kraft
sondern ich meine tatsächlich die
sanktionen die jetzt getroffen wenn die
gemacht werden wer hat im moment wer
muss im moment dafür zahlen die
bevölkerung von russland putin ist es
doch egal ob es im supermarkt noch
nudeln gibt oder nicht das ist eben doch
egal also ich glaub schon dass die
sanktionen für mich als bürgerin als
laie kann ich nur sagen
es wird ein grund dafür geben dass
deswegen machen die menschen diesen job
in der deutschen politik aber mich
wundert es schon sehr dass man erst auf
die bevölkerung auch in russland
tatsächlich jetzt geht und nicht ihn an
die apag paul das war sehr hart von
chelsea haben wir gut ausgedrückt
also ich glaube er versteht kann andere
sprache welche sprache versteht wladimir
putin paul
wenn es so einfach wäre wenn man es
wirklich sagen könnte dann könnten wir
klarer analysieren was wir tatsächlich
tun müssen aber ich glaube tatsächlich
dass wir zu schwach waren in den
vergangenen jahren und dass wir in
gewisser weise auch jetzt noch zu
schwach sind in unserer antwort denn ich
halte es für problematisch dass die usa
wieder vorn geprescht ist und wir nicht
hinterherkommen bei der frage was ein
embargo angeht bei öl und gas jetzt kann
man natürlich darüber sprechen dass uns
das vor größere probleme
stellt und sicherlich muss man dringend
darüber nachdenken was es für menschen
bedeutet die
eben weniger verdienen und
probleme bekommen an der tanksäule da
sind ganz ganz wichtige themen aber
nichtsdestotrotz bleibt ja das gefühl
dass wir weiterhin gas beziehen und öl
von einem mann der hier in dieser stadt
nur zehn kilometer von diesem ort wo ich
gerade bin und wo ich war in ihre pin in
vororten raketen auf menschen runter
regnen lässt auf zivilisten auf familien
auf kinder auf frauen der streumunition
einsetzt der ganz klar oder die jetzt
untersucht werden
kriegsverbrechen begeht und wir
weiterhin dort geld hin schicken und das
ist eine sache mit der ich mich einfach
nicht abfinden möchte und ich fand dort
heute auch in dem interview annalena
baerbock hat man angemerkt dass sie sehr
emotional war dass sie in dem thema auch
sehr drin ist sie hat ja schon vor
jahren gesagt dass nord stream 2
gestoppt werden müsse sie war da sehr
viel klarer als die spd und dennoch ist
jetzt in einer regierung die das eben
nicht will olaf scholz sagt wir sind
davon zu abhängig christian lindner will
es nicht und sie entweder will sie es
tatsächlich nicht oder sie muss diese
position mit verbinden und das
stimmt mich dann schon
ja und da spielt natürlich auch eine
emotionalität eine rolle wenn man jetzt
seit so vielen wochen hier ist als
kriegsberichterstatter und dieses leid
sieht dann geht einem das natürlich
näher das kann ich gar nicht
anders beschreiben und wenn man dann
menschen sieht die nichts mehr haben die
vor allem zusammenbrechen und dann im
nächsten satz sagen aber warum macht der
westen das warum kauft ihr weiter gas
dann so schwer darauf eine antwort zu
geben herr ischinger die frage warum
macht der westen das müssen wir hier
auch vielleicht mal auf die interessen
amerikas blicken palast am anfang
angesprochen dass amerika da mehr
vorprescht ist es denn nicht auch so
dass amerika auch mehr profitieren würde
bei umso stärker die ölpreise steigen
also die gaspreise energiepreise die
ölpreise amerika hat eine sehr starke
ölindustrie gibt es da vielleicht auch
eigeninteressen bei amerika und javi so
reagiert der westen ich wie kann man das
erklären
na ja zunächst einmal ist es natürlich
so dass diese amerikanische entscheidung
voll und gasimporte aus russland jetzt
abzuschneiden amerika relativ weniger
einschneidend schaden wird als das der
fall sein würde wenn wir jetzt das
gleiche tun wird also bei uns wären die
folgen das muss man einfach sachlich
betrachtet
man muss sich die zahlen anschauen bei
uns wären die die die folgen
schwerwiegend dar so ich finde dass
amerika einen richtigen schritt
ergriffen hat selbst wenn der amerika
nicht so hart treffen wird wie das bei
uns der fall sein würde ich persönlich
würde es auch befürworten sein
nachfolger
müsse sicherheitskonferenz christoph
heusgen hat das jetzt sondern auch schon
getan ich schließe mich dem an ich
persönlich würde es für richtig halten
wenn wir diesen schritt gehen würden
aber ich sehe natürlich welchen zwängen
die bundesregierung ausgesetzt ist das
geholt wird groß sein wenn die
energiepreise ins graue steigen und wenn
wenn ihr manches dann auskunft aus der
kontrolle gerät wenn ihr arbeitsplätze
verloren gehen und so weiter wer ist
denn die der schuld das muss man ich
will aber noch ein anderer punkt
hinzufügen wollen sie bei uns einmal hat
ja recht und dass das in verzweiflung
ist ist natürlich groß es gibt zwei wege
druck auf die russische führung zu
erhöhen der eine weg ist der weg den wir
jetzt geht der weg über die sanktionen
der weg über bestimmte waffenlieferungen
die deutsche seite leider erst sehr spät
angefangen haben aber das ist so der
andere weg wäre der weg über inneren
druck aus russland heraus und hier sehe
ich ein bisher völlig ungepflegtes fällt
nach allem was ich persönlich aus
eigenen gesprächen und telefonaten mit
russischen kollegen weiß ist dass zwar
die intellektuelle schicht in moskau
unsere verzweiflung
unsere besorgnisse über diesen
unprovozierten angriffe ich teilen aber
die breite
mehrheit in der russischen bevölkerung
ist der putin gino baganda zum opfer
gefallen und glaubt dass anscheinend bis
zum heutigen tag sein ich frage mich
also nicht die frage in der unter geben
ich bin gar nicht der fachmann nicht als
arbeit wieso sind wir wie so ist der
westen wieso sind die usa wieso ist die
europäische union nicht in der lage mit
allem was wir haben an internet
möglichkeiten
ich will es mal sagen an
jedem einzelnen russen mehrfach am tag
klar zu machen dass sein präsident im
augenblick einen mörderischen krieg im
nachbarland beginnt und das ist
keineswegs so ist dass die ukrainischen
brüder und schwestern die russischen
kompanien und anna mit mit freude
empfangen sondern dass sie sich entgegen
stellt das ist in moskau auf vielleicht
in intellektuellen inzwischen klar aber
es ist im winter aus dem land nicht da
und ich glaube hier muss man ansetzen
und eine große
öffentlichkeitsarbeit kampagne starten
um jeder größten klarzumachen werden das
ist das eigene land ist was ich hiermit
mit schande
und und und auf jahrzehnte hinaus die
russische ehre bisserl die glaube
mussten reagieren auf solche punkte
hoffentlich können wir die nach russland
hineintragen herrschinger das ist ein
ganz toller appel und bei dem dem würde
ich auch gerne das thema schließen und
zum stichwort spritpreise kommen und
damit zum claus strunz und seinem thema
heute abend
also wahrscheinlich ging es ja jedem
unserer zuschauer soeben mir im studio
so wenn man heute an die drei schilder
geguckt hat bei tankstellen hier sehen
was hier waren enorme preise zu sehen
immerhin
2,2 eur 35 habe ich irgendwo sehen der
durchschnitt für einen liter e10 war bei
zwei euro und einem cent unglaublich
noch vor wenigen wochen hätte man
gedacht es kommt nie und wenn es kommt
dann haben uns die politiker lindner
wissing verkehrsminister linden der
finanzminister jetzt olaf scholz kanzler
jetzt da waren sie alters noch nicht in
ihren ämtern da war noch wahlkampf da
haben sie uns allen versprochen das
kommt auf keinen fall da können sie sich
auf uns verlassen also benzin darf nicht
zum luxusgut werden nein nein wir können
auf keinen fall familien in die pleite
treiben wir können auf keinen fall zur
armut beitragen wir müssen die mobilität
hochhalten all das ist versprochen
worden und jetzt sagt nach der wahl
lernen wir in einem konkreten
sachverhalt versprochen ist versprochen
und wird halt dann doch gebrochen also
das ist etwas was ein ja schon ein
bisschen emotionalisiert und es wird
noch schlimmer wenn man sich christian
lindner jetzt anhört jetzt zieht er
nämlich durchs land und sagt er könne
die mehrwertsteuer auf benzin gar nicht
senken weil das insgesamt ja sozusagen
gar nicht zu einer wirklichen entlastung
beitragen würde und dann kommt ein ich
meine worte dafür sind technisches
geschwurbel das ist ziemlich dreist weil
er könnte es natürlich er könnte es
sofort er könnte es morgen verkünden und
anordnen aber er will nicht und warum
will er nicht weil er ganz kräftig daran
mitverdient an jedem cent in dem das
benzin teurer wird verdient der staat ja
mit der finanzminister auch und jetzt
kommt das aller allerbeste
das ist ja gar nicht sein geld was er da
einnimmt sondern unseres und deshalb
glaube ich dass sie die stunde gekommen
ist wo ganz konkret der
bundesfinanzminister an die seite der
bürger treten muss deren geld er
verwaltet und für sie agieren muss und
nicht gegen sie und in letzter zeit ist
mir aufgefallen bezieht sich christian
lindner immer häufiger auf seinen
amtseid dem wohle des volkes dienen zu
müssen das stimmt dem wohle des volkes
verdienen heißt aber nicht nur ein krieg
vermeiden sondern auch vermeiden dass
familien pleite gehen und deshalb ist
ganz klar die stunde christian lindner
zuzurufen herr finanzminister
senken sie die mehrwertsteuer auf benzin
und zwar dramatisch ich würde
vorschlagen von 19 auf 7 prozent und
zwar sofort
frauen brauchen die spritpreis bremser
für die bürger absolut
fertig ja also das ist ja wirklich
besser klare erklärung kam gerade von
den studios und ich denke mir irgendwie
das also ich kann sie verstehen dass man
jetzt darüber diskutiert ich habe auch
eingesehen in der sendung hier gestern
oder sowas war dabei auch sagte dass im
grundgesetz verankert er kann es nicht
machen verstehe ich gar nichts von war
ich kenne das grundgesetz jetzt nicht
auswendig und weiß nicht in welchem
paragrafen dasteht ich kann es auch
nicht checken gegen strecken in dem
moment dann will er nicht schulden
machen bei unseren enkeln et cetera für
mich und ich bin eigentlich ein
christian lindner fan muss ich sagen ich
mochte den immer sehr und ich fand dann
immer sehr sympathisch dann doch immer
sehr gut gesprochen ich habe ihn
verstanden das reicht mir meistens bei
der politik nichts desto trotz fand ich
in dem moment dachte ich so nee das
reicht mir nicht wenn man muss ehrlich
sein er verwendet ein argument über das
man eine sekunde nachdenken muss er sagt
ja das würde im prinzip wenig bringen
wenn er das täte weil die menschen die
jetzt mehr geld für benzin ausgeben
woran er mehr verdient geben dieses geld
ja für andere dinge nicht aus deswegen
verdient da gar nicht wirklich mehr
sondern da verliert er sogar einnahmen
und wenn man dann mal kurz drüber
nachdenken stellt man fest herr lindner
das stimmt aber es setzt irgendwie ein
falsches paradigma voraus nämlich dass
der staat immer genauso viel geld
einnehmen muss man könnte er in einer
krisenzeit auch mal sagen man gibt es
zurück man hat nicht mehr so viel geld
wie vorher sondern man gibt es zurück
und wenn ich mir überlege was wir alles
in zukunft bezahlen müssen also
300 milliarden corona und das ist nur
der anfang gewesen
100 milliarden
[Musik]
verteidigungsausgaben da wird jetzt
schon der eindruck erweckt das ist halt
jetzt zu geld sondervermögen lindner
sagt immer das leid man sich aus der
zukunft also das heißt so dass alles so
indirekt die wahrheit ist ja dass
irgendwann zahltag sein wird und jeder
von uns kann jetzt schon mal fünf
prozent seines haushalts netto zur seite
legen für das was dann über steuern über
abgaben über irgendwelches so ließ über
sonst was auf uns zukommen wird und in
einer solchen situation wie jetzt wo
menschen schon durch eine inflation von
5% und diese sorge was kommt da in der
zukunft noch auf mich zu sowieso schon
finanziell angespannt sind müsste der
staat eigentlich sagen zu unserer
haushalterischen verantwortung gehört
jetzt beim benzin zu sagen wir geben was
zurück bzw wir nehmen es nicht noch mehr
ein denn es muss man schon mal sagen
alles was jetzt teurer wird zehn cent
teurer bedeutet auch viele viele cent
für den staat mehr und die wenigstens
die wenigsten soll ja nicht zusätzlich
einnehmen sonst hatten wir nämlich das
gefühl er bereichert sich irgendwie in
der situation die wir jetzt haben ich
finde auch und was eben nicht alles was
ich nicht habe war der moment eine
sekunde nachlassen da aus dem oft fast
schon treuherzig gehört ich habe
freiwillig unterbleiben ich wollte ich
wollte ich wollte frau würde ich gerne
hier unterbrechen wir haben nur ein bild
hoch bei dieser debatte um die
benzinpreise und ich stelle mich ich
stelle die frage in diesen tagen wie
sehr das das mag zwar populistisch
klingen aber politiker tatsächlich noch
nachvollziehen können denn heute gab es
ein video von tobias hans dem
ministerpräsidenten vom saarland der 111
video gemacht hat und das erstaunliche
war nicht dasselbe video und die
litfaßsäule sondern dass man im
hintergrund seine dienstlimousine
gesehen hat also nicht nur seine sondern
auch die der sicherheit und da fragt man
sich natürlich wie nah sind solche
politiker dann noch bei den menschen
tatsächlich und tanken sie tatsächlich
noch selbst das gleiche habe ich mal
wahlkampf langes her vor dem ukraine
krieg und vielen anderen dingen ich
glaube im juni war es olaf scholz
gefragt den damaligen kanzlerkandidaten
von dem damals noch jeder gesagt hatte
er würde niemals kanzler werden und als
ich ihm diese frage gestellt habe ob er
denn wisse wie hoch der benzinpreis ist
dann musste er sagen will das weiß er
nicht und das liege auch daran dass er
eigentlich gar nicht mehr selbst tank
weil er hat ja sicherheit und die
sicherheit tankt ja also wie sehr in
diesem kosmos berlin sind überhaupt die
politiker noch imstande zu realisieren
was die tankfüllung für die gesamte
familie bedeutet ja die rächen denn ist
wahrscheinlich eher in schnipseln
beuchert um das ist das edle restaurants
und sagen na ja gott dann ist halt so
ich habe aber nur in anderen punkt der
mich beschleicht also pauls gedanke dass
die politiker möglicherweise gar nicht
mehr in der wirklichkeit verankert sind
ist reizvoll und stimmt auch glaube ich
habe noch einen anderen gedanken wer
mich beschleicht der ist fast ein
bisschen tabulos in diesen tagen des
krieges wir haben natürlich zwei
regierungsparteien denen es gefällt dass
der spritpreis steigt die spd und die
grünen weil mit steigendem spritpreis
und dem leid der menschen was ich jetzt
sozusagen dieses lamentieren der leute
über spritpreis heißt ja immer auch naja
hättest den lastenfahrrad dann bräuchte
es da auch kein benzin hättest du im
auto dann bräuchte es da auch kein
benzin würdest du mehr zu fuß gehen dann
weiß ich dass da auch kein benzin
wir vertrauen euch so wie es euch auto
fahren sowieso gerade alle innenstädte
mit allen möglichen radwegen die kreuz
und quer gehen worüber man sich aufregen
kann also das volk schon auch einer
gewissen logik und es könnte sein dass
der von ihr bewunderte christian lindner
der auch einsteiger 100 habe ich nicht
gefährdet aus sicht
von deere fendt
der ja auch ein
potente politiker ist in dieser
konstellation
möglicherweise gar nicht anders kann als
zu sagen die benzinpreise sind mein
kleinstes problem ich habe ganz andere
und das schimmert alles durch durch
diesen eigentlich unvorstellbaren
tatbestand dass politik was zugunsten
der bürger ändern könnte aber es einfach
nicht macht ja aber jetzt mal ganz im
ernst können wir wirklich davon ausgehen
jetzt ernsthaft gesprochen dass ein
politiker der bundeskanzler von
deutschland das sehr normales leben gibt
das können wir doch jetzt auch nicht
unterstellen man kann jetzt sagen die
sind realitätsfern natürlich sind die
realitätsferne dass der bundeskanzler
in schillig nicht dass das geschadet mit
stolz war deshalb so schön weil wir eben
am nächsten tag vorgerechnet haben an
wie viele tankstellen er von seinem
amtssitz bis zu seiner wohnung
vorbeifährt und einfach nur aus dem
fenster schauen müsste um den
benzinpreis herauszufinden ich glaube da
ist was dran das ist ein lebendes ich
verstehe die grundaussage und die
kernaussage und dann gehen und ich will
noch eines sagen jetzt aber sei nie
vergessen dürfen politiker ist dass sie
ja quasi nicht einfach so für sich da
sind sondern sie sind von uns gewählt
damit sie unsere interessen vertreten
und es gibt kein interesse an einem
durch die decke explodierende
benzinpreis von niemanden außer ob lass
mich nachdenken der finanzminister wie
gesagt krieg mehr und das nicht auch
aufregt und was auch ein bisschen wenig
diskutiert wird ist noch ist der ölpreis
ja gar nicht so viel höher also das
höher als vor ein paar wochen aber das
was jetzt in dem preis drin steckt der
wissen seit 2000 ja ja aber er ist noch
nicht so hoch wie die sogleich unter
sich ist aber noch nicht so hoch wie der
benzinpreis worauf ich aus will ist die
mineralölfirmen antizipieren natürlich
was kommen wird und hauen es jetzt schon
auf den preis das heißt auch shell aral
wie sie alle heißen machen sich in der
zwischenzeit natürlich die taschen voll
und das finde ich ist mindestens so
interessant zu durchleuchten wie die
forderung die mehrwertsteuer zu senken
stell mir dennoch als letzte frage zu
diesem thema die frage ein herr
ischinger hersteller wie haben sie
selber hier schon debattiert wie nah
sind die politiker dennoch am alltag der
menschen dran gibt es dort handlungs und
wie oft denken sie selber
also müssen sie ich habe mir in meiner
diplomatischen 22
sie sprach in washington in sondern wenn
ich das so vergleiche miteinander dann
muss ich jetzt doch eine gewisse
ehrenerklärung für die deutsche
politiker rege abgeben ich glaube die
sind relativ betrachten doch noch weit
näher an ihren mitbürgern an ihren
wahlkreisen als die total zum teil total
abgehoben dem britischen politiker also
ich denke jetzt nicht nur an den
personen boris johnson auch mit so
manchem im house of lords ich denke an
amerikanischer politiker senatoren die
die vollkommen die fassung und die die
die bodenhaftung verloren haben denkt
sie an die an die tramper und ich denke
auch an so manchen in frankreich also da
scheint mir das größte problem
deutschlands nicht hinzulegen glaube der
durchschnittliche bund deutsche
bundestagsabgeordnete am mittag durch
staatssekretär und minister der ist
eigentlich noch relativ nahe an den
bürgern an und das ist ja ganz gut so
das dürfte erleichterung beim zuschauer
wecken die politiker sind doch noch
nicht so abgehoben und damit kommen wir
nun zu meinem thema die auch uns alle
alle bürger betreffen werden denn mein
thema heute abend sind die der
sanktionen meine these ist die sanktion
bestrafen auch und selbst der krieg ist
furchtbar wir müssen russland stoppen
für die freiheit einstehen aber jede
sanktion für russland da müssen wir auch
ehrlich sein schadet uns in deutschland
ebenfalls nicht immer im selben ausmaß
aber sie schadet die wirtschaftlichen
verflechtungen sind einfach zu groß
nicht nur beim thema energie wenn wir
die 27 milliarden euro exporte von
deutschland nach russland sanktionieren
leiden darunter unsere unternehmen denen
diese umsätze wegfallen die zahl von 27
milliarden scheint abstrakt groß und
anonym aber lassen sie es mich einmal
anders ausdrücken
2700 unternehmen also fast zehn
unternehmen die landkreis dem jeweils
und jedes jahr ein zehn millionen
auftrag abhanden kommt dass es für viele
mittelständler existenzgefährdend und
führt unweigerlich zu kurzarbeit
entlassungen schlimmerem wirtschaftliche
sanktionen sind natürlich das kleinere
übel im vergleich zu kriegerischen
handlungen aber wir dürfen bei aller
euphorie für immer härtere sanktionen
auch nicht vergessen dass für jede
bestrafung russland wir uns auch selber
bestrafen die wirtschaft ist der motor
unseres landes und es muss uns
alarmieren dass die ersten unternehmen
aufgrund der steigenden energiepreise
produktionsanlagen ausstellen die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer industrie
es gefährdet und die lage ist dramatisch
die außenministerin der berbalk hat
heute hier bei bild gesagt zitat nur
sanktionen werden den krieg nicht
stoppen sollen wir müssen alle möglichen
kanäle nutzen paul außerhalb der
sanktionen welche kanäle können wir noch
nutzen
ich glaube dass tatsächlich die sanktion
das entscheidende sind überhaupt dafür
zu sorgen dass wladimir putin bereit
sein wird über bestimmte dinge zu
sprechen und ich glaube dass die
sanktionen das einzige mittel sind am
ende auch dafür zu sorgen dass die
russische bevölkerung merkt was der
russische präsident dort tut denn ich
gebe wolfgang ischinger vollkommen recht
auch wenn man sich anschaut wie groß die
anzahl derjenigen ist die noch immer
hinter ihrem präsidenten stehen und wir
tatsächlich hierdurch
eine babbel in berlin und überall
vielleicht eine falsche wahrnehmung
dessen haben
das massen fernsehen dort sorgt für
perfekte grausame propaganda also ich
hab gerade erst wieder gesehen wie dort
ukrainische häftlinge vorgeführt wurden
die dann all das wiederholt haben was
putin in seiner rede gesagt hat dass
hier in der ukraine über nazis sind das
ist alles ganz schlimm ist dass die
nato-staaten mit krieg führen also
erschafft dieses konstrukt und ich finde
dass deshalb auch so deprimierend weil
wir eigentlich mal 2010 gedacht haben
mensch durch facebook twitter durch
social media wird das alles viel viel
freier und diktatoren und diktaturen
haben keine chance mehr so das lenkt
jetzt von dem thema sanktionen wieder
etwas ab aber tatsächlich ist es so ich
glaube man kann nicht so einfach sagen
es ist nur putin
und
der rest sozusagen russland kann nichts
dafür nein die haben diesen mann gewählt
die unterstützen ihn noch immer und die
müssen jetzt verstehen dass das was sie
dort tun einen verbrecherischen krieg zu
führen einen krieg zu führen der kinder
sterben lässt frauen sterben lässt der
städte in schutt und asche legt dass das
massivste konsequenzen hat
einschneidendste konsequenzen hat und
aus meiner sicht können die sanktion gar
nicht scharf genug sein paul es geht mir
bei meiner these überhaupt nicht darum
dass ich sage wir dürfen müssen jetzt
russland schützen und sollten deswegen
keine sanktionen machen sondern es geht
mir um die wirksamkeit wenn deutschland
diese sanktion umsetzt ja und damit auch
mit blick auf höhe zum beispiel denn
kann russland ja weiter nach china
verkaufen und dadurch dass die preise
immer mehr steigen wird auch der verlust
in russland kompensiert meine einzige
frage ist dementsprechend wie viel
werden unsere sanktionen denn auch mit
blick auf die rolle chinas überhaupt
nutzen und können wir mit den sanktionen
wirklich diesen krieg beenden wenn man
sie das so sein kompensieren kann mit
china und all die anderen faktoren
einbegriffen
ich glaube das sollte uns einfach
erstmal gar nicht interessieren weil
daran können wir nichts ändern was china
macht wir können natürlich versuchen
einfluss auf china zu nehmen durch
diplomaten diplomatische kanäle und die
deutsche wirtschaft ist dort auch
wichtig also all das können wir tun aber
zunächst einmal müssen wir doch unsere
unserer eigenen wertesystem folgen wir
müssen doch unserer moral folgen und
sagen das was hier passiert das
akzeptieren wir nicht und das wird
bestraft und das muss so solche
konsequenzen haben solch einschneidenden
konsequenzen haben das dass vladimir
putin merkt und wenn er es nicht merkt
dann sein umfeld also die debatte die
sehe ich nicht
habe ich mich damals schon gerne gesehen
also ich würde gerne ja ich würde gerne
zwei punkt gemacht
erstens
sanktionen sind nie ein allheilmittel
sanktionen haben immer die medikamente
auch nebenwirkungen und bin deswegen
muss man den beipackzettel genau liest
sie haben das ja gerade vor geteilt und
1 um zwei
sanktionen gegen russland
müssen wir so gestalten dass er normale
rosse die normale russinnen nicht das
gefühl bekommt die wollen mich bestrafen
wir müssen die sanktionen so
maßschneidern dass sie die russische
elite die führungsschicht die
geheimdienste die kreise um putin
wenigen die die inhaber der macht sind
wenn ich wenn ich mir eine minute und
einer bibliothek geben erzähle ich noch
eine kleine anekdote die dazu passen als
angela merkel als neue bundeskanzlerin
anfang 2006 nach washington und ihr
erstes gespräch als deutsche
bundeskanzlerin mit george bush sprach
fragte der sie was halten sie
angela sagte er was halten sie denn
eigentlich von sanktionen gegen teheran
damals ging es um diese frage und
baumberg und sagte wissen sie mit den
sanktionen ist das so eine sache
als ich in der ddr aufwuchs war meine
familie war mein vater man die eltern
eigentlich eher gegner des
kommunistischen systems in moskau und
wollten sich durchaus wenn da aus
washington dann mal sanktionen gegen
die damalige kommunistische führung in
der sowjetunion ergriffen wurden wenn
aber diese sanktionen dazu führten dass
wir in der in mecklenburg vorpommern da
in ihrer heimatstadt
plötzlich keine orangen oder bananen
mehr bekamen dann dachten wir werden
nicht bestraft wir haben doch gar nichts
gemacht das ist genau der zentrale punkt
können wir diese aktionen so gestalten
dass der normale busse weiß das bild der
führung die hat hier verbrecherische
gewalttaten verübt das gilt aber nicht
und die russen ihr essen sind nämlich
eigentlich unseren großen nachbarn und
freunde und diese beziehung sollten wir
natürlich langfristig pflegen und
erhalten es geht um grund ihn und seine
crew ließ und es geht nicht um eine
feindschaft mit russland
naja ich glaube dass das das natürlich
um ihr wort zu nehmen maßgeschneidert
ist es so zu machen aber ich denke dass
doch danach eine kleine ergänzung zu
machen oder nicht 2 wenn wir jetzt also
leere supermarktregale sehen sehen wir
ja schon dass es nicht funktioniert hat
das maßzuschneidern denn die leere
supermarktregale werden bedeuten dass
die russische propaganda sagt da könnte
man sehen was der böse westen mit euch
macht jetzt wollen sie verhungern lassen
dann ist diese gedankliche übertragung
nee das ist ja eine sanktion der
regierung gegenüber und deshalb müssen
können wir jetzt nicht mehr einkaufen
das wird ist schon viel verlangt ich
will aber auch noch was ergänzt was mir
in letzter zeit schwer fällt aber es
muss immer mal gesagt werden
natürlich haben sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr viele
russen wladimir putin gewählt und die
können jetzt nicht sagen wir haben mit
dem krieg nichts zu tun das können sie
nicht sagen also denn zwar ist es eine
sagen wir mal
perverse form sein staatsoberhaupt zu
wählen wie das in russland funktioniert
es gibt ja wenn ich es richtig sehe
wenig wirkliche alternativen aber man
kann ja nicht sagen putin war mein
geliebter präsident und jetzt macht er
aber und er hat jetzt das kriegführen
nicht erst vorgestern erfunden sondern
hat sich ja schon ein teil der ukraine
vorher einverleibt also alle die ihn
danach noch mal gewählt haben haben auch
gewählt den expansionsdrang von putin
und deshalb finde ich es auch einen
gedanken wert ob man nicht auch das ein
bisschen mit sanktioniert
paar möchtest du noch was entgegnen du
hast unsere debatte gehört ich hoffe ja
immer dass die verbindung genau zu dir
immer weitergeht ich habe da immer ein
bisschen angst war das irgendwie gipfel
plötzlich aber das ist alles geld möchte
noch was ja wieder
nein ich bin da tatsächlich eher auf der
seite von claus strunz denn ich glaube
auch dass es nicht funktionieren wird zu
sagen
sanktionieren ausschließlich oder machen
diese zielgerichteten sanktionen gegen
die putin kreise die werden trotzdem
ihren weg finden die idee müsste ja sein
oder der hintergrund bei dem was putin
dort gerade macht und wie er vorgeht
dass wir ein interesse daran haben dass
menschen auf die straße gehen und
verstehen was dieser präsident dort und
natürlich kann man auch das für ein
verhalten weil sicherlich wladimir putin
es schaffen wird dann ihre not dem
westen zuzuschreiben hat wolfgang
ischinger dennoch recht aber ich glaube
dass die situation mittlerweile eine
solch dramatische ist dass wir nicht
sagen können okay oligarch xy dafür sich
mehr nach europa reisen und seine villa
konfiszieren wir und seine bankkonten in
der schweiz und dann war es das glaube
da kommen wir nicht mehr weiter ich hab
noch ein punkt der mir wichtig ist weil
er uns alle betrifft jetzt zur
diskussionen neigen ja manchmal dazu
dass man immer sagt was die anderen
machen sollen sanktionen und das war ja
wenn ich es richtig verstanden aber auch
keinen punkt treffen uns auch hart und
wir bestrafen uns selber ich finde man
muss schon einmal die
übersetzungsleistung leisten auch in so
einem forum zu sagen wenn wir uns als
bundesrepublik an einer sanktionen gegen
russland beteiligen wird jeden einzelnen
von uns das was kosten also wer jetzt
sagt sanktionen sind richtig muss auch
sagen und ich bin auch mit 10 100 1000
10.000 euro dabei damit meine ich keine
spenden damit meine ich sozusagen
weniger ausgeben für energie damit meine
ich
frieren für den frieden statt
krieg führen für den frieden wir können
nicht sagen die sanktionen sind
irgendwie sowas was die da verlieren
sagen arbeitslosigkeit für die herren
gegen köln dabei sagen nicht sagen die
sanktion ist irgendwas was da so
politische apparate irgendwie verhängen
und dann funktionieren die vielleicht
sondern eine sanktion ist eine
gemeinsame willenserklärung des westens
selber auch verzicht zu leisten für das
höhere gut um dass es dann dem konflikt
geht und ich glaube das muss auch erst
noch durchdringen ich will eins ergänzen
letztes ich habe manchmal das gefühl
dass diese große welle der
hilfsbereitschaft sich jetzt für
flüchtlinge zu engagieren auch was damit
zu tun hat dass menschen zeigen wollen
das ist mein beitrag ein ganz konkreter
beitrag ich nehme jemanden auf und setze
damit ein zeichen putin du kannst die
menschen vertreiben aber sie werden nie
heimatlos weil ich gebe ihnen eine neue
jedenfalls auf zeit das ist stärke und
vielleicht müssen wir noch sehr viel
mehr auf diese symbolik sitzen über
spenden und wie man auch mitmachen kann
immer solidarität da aber spricht nach
der werbung charlotte würde und hören
auch herr ischinger die eine sehr
spannende these mitgebracht das
versprechen bis gleich
[Musik]
hierbei fielen nach acht wollen wir ja
nie auch nur eine sendezeit verlieren
wir geben direkt weiter an wolfgang
ischinger und sein thema ist
ja vielen dank mein thema ist ein ganz
einfach ich hatte vorhin ja schon gesagt
wir müssen die gesprächskanäle offen
halten es ist zwar verständlich
wenn
menschen jetzt danach fragen wann können
wir denn endlich vladimir putin vor das
den internationalen strafgerichtshof in
den haag
kommen wann sind wir da auf der anlage
an ich will nur darauf hinweisen wenn
wir der meinung sind das ist vielleicht
die aussichten eine automatische
verhandlungslösung egal die dann im
einzelnen aussehen war er hinzu dann
müssen wir eine russischen führung haben
die nicht im gefängnis in den haag sitzt
sondern wie der mann verhandeln ich habe
persönlich
erlebt wie kommt es dass sein kann ich
war der deutsche unterhändler als es um
den frieden in austin mitte der
neunziger jahre denken und die
eigentlichen messe täter die eigentlich
die unterschrift unter den vertrag
hätten leisten sollen die bosnischen
serben den durften gar nicht nach usa
reisen dort wo die prinz behandlung
stattfanden weil sie angeklagt waren vor
diesem jugoslawischen
kriegsverbrechertribunal und deswegen
gar nicht erscheinen konnte und der
ganze prozess des friedensvertrags wäre
damals gescheitert wenn nicht der
serbische präsident milosevic ein fach
gebracht zu haben für die kosten mission
serbe unterschrieb ich will damit nur
sagen wir brauchen
jedenfalls jetzt und für die
vorhersehbare zeit eine
handlungsfähige russische führung mit
der man verhandeln kann die zeit
diese leute und oben bis runter zum
letzten sechs soldaten vor das
kriegsverbrechertribunal zu ziehen die
kommt danach ich warne davor jetzt
anfangen zu spinnen wir haben die wir
könnten ja jetzt auch gar nicht fangen
wer behindert sein und nach den aktien
lassen sie uns bei dem bleiben was im
augenblick wichtig ist nämlich nach der
beendigung möglichkeiten zu suchen
militärisch hoffentlich dazu beizutragen
dass sie kein nicht untergeht und nach
diplomatischen möglichkeiten zu suchen
wenn gut in seine maximalist ischen
forderungen etwas reduziert könnte es ja
sein dass es zumindest zu einem
waffenstillstand und darf dazu brauchen
wir einen handlungsfähigen
russischen präsidenten dazu brauchen wir
einen handlungsfähigen russischen
verteidigungsminister die zeit für die
kriegsverbrechen regionale die kommt
hinzu kommt danach
charlotte diplomatie ist natürlich immer
der schönste weg verstehst dann auch die
heiße wut von menschen seit er sogar ein
us amerikaner gefordert man sollte putin
killen verstehens verstehst du diese wut
von menschen auch mit dem kriegs
tribunal wasser angesprochen hat ja ich
kann das schon verstehen aber wir wissen
alle aus dem mini mini vergleichbaren
kreis dass man eigentlich besser und
weiter kommt wenn man vernünftig
sprechen kann als der mann darf einander
los geht
das ist natürlich superschön die these
also die idee klingt wirklich toll im
moment sehe ich jetzt nicht so wirklich
die bereitschaft seitens putins sich
normal zu unterhalten sich vernünftig zu
unterhalten eine lösung zu finden ich
finde er arbeitet im moment nicht
wirklich lösungsorientiert für die welt
und deshalb finde ich das ein bisschen
schwierig es ist ein schöner gedanke im
spiel es ist toll und ich hoffe dass
dieses spiel aufgeht das wäre natürlich
für alle das alles beste aller beste was
passieren könnte
aber im moment muss ich leider sagen
sehe ich da einfach nicht viel hoffnung
also ich glaube auch nicht ehrlich sagt
dass putin angst vor dem westen hat ich
habe glaube auch nicht dass er angst vor
der nato hat oder
die sanktionen im moment bin ich glaube
der hat angst im endeffekt vor
demokratie das ist das was eben nicht
schlafen lassen und ich glaube auch
nicht dass er irgendwie verrückt ist
oder sonst irgendwas sondern dass er ein
ganz kalt macht stratege ist und ich
finde den gedanken ist mal ins
privatleben zu holen eigentlich reizvoll
wir stellen uns mal vor wir haben
nachbarn zwei kleine reihenhäuser und
der sagt ich will dein haus
und ich mache jetzt so das leben zur
hölle ich komme erst in den garten dann
schließlich die spielsachen deiner
kinder zusammen dann schwierig deine
wand voll ich will dein haus dann musste
bevor du ins gespräch gehst der du
überlegen was du anbietet solltest du
anbieten du kriegst zwei quadratmetern
meinem garten mein haus kannst du haben
das macht ja kein mensch also das
bedeutet aber was macht man damit zum
nachbarn in der zivilen welt bleibt
einem als letztes noch wegzuziehen und
aufzugeben das ist jetzt sozusagen
völkerrechtlich und als staat deutlich
schwieriger aber das beispiel zeigt
womit wir es zu tun haben und ich glaube
auch am verhandlungstisch david michels
meinung interessieren
am verhandlungstisch wird putin dann
auch nicht sagen ich will gar nicht dein
haus sondern nur den vorgarten sondern
da wird sagen ich will das haus weil mir
das zu steht früher im grundbuch von 420
vor 500 jahren steht drin war ich mal
der eigentümer und ich will es jetzt
haben du hast das zwar gekauft und schön
gemacht aber ich möchte jetzt und ich
hole mir das jetzt und übrigens deine
autoreifen hab ich auch schon zerstochen
und gucken wir da eine windschutzscheibe
an und deine kinder trauten sich nicht
mehr ins haus vom schulweg und der ist
da ein terrorist am nach am terror ist
am gartenzaun wie geht man mit dem
diplomatisch um mir fallen da nur sehr
martialische sachen ein die werden dann
aber hochgerechnet jetzt auf die
weltlage die die sich keiner wünscht
naja es ist ja es ist natürlich so
diplomatie ohne militär
wird sehr schnell zum
nutzlosen gerät und jedes jahr über im
zentrum das geschäft ist es eine
wichtige erkenntnis
in der diplomatie dass wir dass wir
durch militärische stärke finden müssen
müssen mit dem diplomatischen angebot
was heißt das jetzt konkret in der in
der aktuellen lage in der ukraine
solange die russische führung der
meinung ist dass sie diesen krieg
gewinnen kann ohne dass sie denn die
unterstützung der mehrheit der
russischen bevölkerung verliert da wird
die verhandlungsbereitschaft gut ins
unserer leute nicht groß sein in dem
augenblick in dem sich zweifel
einstellen ob die innenpolitische front
11 und ob die militärische sieges
erwartungen tatsächlich aufrecht halten
werden kann in dem augenblick wird die
verhandlungsbereitschaft steigen ich
wage keine prognose fast einmaligen
tatenlosen passieren aber wir haben eine
chance dass es zu gesprächen komme und
das ist mir das wichtig ich will nicht
dass die untergraben wird und es stört
wird ja ich möchte auch nicht dass wir
der russischen regierung den vorwand
eben die im westen die wollen ja gar
nicht den frieden in der ukraine so und
die wollen regime change in moskau und
deswegen die bewussten müsst ihr euch
alle um mich zu sammeln weil das ja
einen angriff auf unser heiliges
vaterland wäre das ist zum beispiel
schlechte wäre schlechte diplomatie
diplomatie ist
nicht verbal zu eskalieren sondern
besonnen zu reagieren
ich bewundere in diesem zusammenhang
jetzt in dieser lage anders als in den
letzten jahren die art und weise wie die
amerikanische regierung sich verhält sie
hat nicht verbal eskaliert sie hat auch
nicht nuklear eskaliert auf die nuklear
handlungen der der russischen seite das
fand ich jetzt ausnahmsweise mal aus
washington kommen sehr lobenswert paar
kannst du kurz noch reagieren damit sich
schon weiter zum thema von frau würde
falschen leute würde weil sonst kommt es
heute nicht mehr dran ganz ganz schnell
weil wenn wir schon so einer erfahrenen
großartigen experten wie wolfgang
ischinger haben möchte ich doch eine
frage auch von von von hier loswerden
und zwar sehen wir jetzt gerade die
nachrichten dass polen bereit ist
kampfjets hier in die an die ukraine zu
geben das lief gerade als breaking news
ich glaube im gegenzug werden diese
alten sowjetischen kampfjets
ausgetauscht dann durch amerikanische
aber das bedeutete am ende polen schickt
kampfjets in die ukraine jetzt hat
wladimir putin angekündigt dass
diejenigen die die ukraine mit soetwas
ausstatten am ende auch als kriegspartei
gelten können rechnen sie damit dass das
vladimir putin in einer weiteren weise
sozusagen
aggressiv stimmen wird dass man erste
frage und die zweite ist was bedeutet
wenn sie sagen dass wladimir putin
glauben sie dass er ernsthaft verstehen
würde wenn er zu hause die kontrolle
verliert weil er ja so einem engen
zirkel ist von beratern keiner kommen
wir an ihnen dran also wer sonst dann
überhaupt erzählen dass es
innenpolitisch schwierig wird für ihn
herrscht in ganz kurzer an von
ihrerseits ganz kurz ja uns gut auf
diese frage auf den grund mit fünf ganz
kurze antwort putin hat es doch in der
hand den sieg zu erklären er hat doch
die öffentliche meinung in sachen in der
anerkannt auch sagen wir haben das ziel
erreicht die werden dieses ziel der nato
mitgliedschaft nicht weiterverfolgen
flugfans condor jetzt gehören dauerhaft
uns und die ukraine verzichtet
militärisch gegen die krämpfe zu gehen
große sieg russland hat geworden kann er
jeden tag erklärt sich das ist das ist
ja der der taktischen vorteil der nahe
und ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass
ein solcher punkt kommt wo er aus
unserer sicht ein nicht sieht erklärt
aber an ein nicht sie der in russland
als sieg des präsidenten
interpretiert werden würde das wäre eine
bittere situation ich hoffe dass sie so
nicht andere hersteller sie müssen auf
jeden fall auch mal wiederkommt ich hab
nämlich jetzt auch noch eine frage an
sie aber wir machen jetzt weiter mit
frau würde ich's thema heute abend
so und ich mache es kurz ich meine these
ist jeder muss jetzt herrschen
das ist die these und ich glaube das
steht ja auch mal nicht mehr viel zeit
und ich höre keine widerworte also
bleibt er auch bestehen es war die
grösste synthese die jeweils dabei war
und lange herumreden ist leider wahr
meint ich bin wirklich ich bin ich bin
begeistert davon wie geholfen wird rbb
wie das organisierte was jeder die frage
der zukunft ist also nicht bist du
geimpft sondern wie hast du geholfen ja
zusätzlich zum thema wirst du geimpft
ist das darf man ja nicht ganz vergessen
dass das thema auch noch gibt aber ja
ich finde ich finde jeder hat es auch
vor allem in jeder kann helfen es wird
in der regel gibt es noch mal für die
zuschauer nicht so helfen ob das jetzt
geldspenden sind sachspenden sind es
kann auch einfach sein dass man sagt
okay ich verzichte auf einen coffee to
go morgens und das mache ich jetzt eine
woche lang und dafür ständig das geld
was ich da gespart habe zum beispiel
oder ich guck was im kleiderschrank ab
weil sie dich brauche gibt das eine oder
andere teil bei uns frauen solche sachen
und da glaube ich daran jeder jetzt mal
ganz kurz zu hause überlegen worauf kann
ich verzichten was könnte ich gehen
lassen und das dann zu einer bestimmten
sammelstelle bringen zum beispiel neben
der spenden und ich finde ein
spendenaufruf so wichtig du hast es hier
auch schon bei ein herz für kinder gegen
gemacht und dazu aufgerufen im gespräch
mit janina kirsch du hast ja selber
kinder charlotte und ich habe mich
gefragt wie erklärt man kindern denn
jetzt eigentlich dass krieg herrschte
bekommen die da schon mit oder wie macht
man das als mutter es ist ein wahnsinnig
schwieriges thema weil ich eigentlich
dachte wir hätten damit abgeschlossen
das ist das nicht gibt das wurde mir
immer von der politik erzählt das ist
jetzt keine kriege mehr diese richtung
geben wird jetzt haben wir doch nämlich
ein und ich habe das versucht sehr klar
und strukturiert zu erklären ich kann
den meinen kindern natürlich nicht
verheimlichen dass krieg schrecklich ist
dass es brutal ist und dass menschen
sterben aber ich kann es versuchen
anhand eines beispiels zum beispiel am
schulhof wenn der streit entsteht dann
kommen die erzieher und schlichten das
ist die nato als ich versuche so ein
bisschen das ganze so sachlich
aufzuarbeiten aber natürlich bleiben die
ängste natürlich bleiben die fragen
warum darf er das wir warum macht er das
und müssen wir angst haben hier zu hause
ist manchmal sind wir hier sicher wo
kämen wir denn hin wenn wir hier
wegmüssen und ich glaube tatsächlich
dass es auch okay ist als mama auch zu
sagen ich es ist nicht schatz ich weiß
es wirklich nicht
das finde ich müsste man fast auch
manchmal zu den erwachsenen gegenseitig
auch sagen dass man es nicht weiß ich
möchte die sendung gerne enten wie auch
in den letzten tagen mit paul ronzheimer
als eindrücken dann für die erwachsenen
und nicht für die kinder das leiden noch
40 sekunden
ich möchte darüber sprechen was vitali
klitschko heute nach einem interview
gesagt habe wo ich ihn mal wieder zum
zehnten mal wahrscheinlich gefragt habe
vitali was machst du eigentlich für
deine sicherheit wie überlebst du das
hier und er mich lange angeguckt hat
nichts gesagt hat und dann sagte ich
bleibe hier ich
könnte sonst nicht mehr in den spiegel
schauen wenn ich mein land verlassen
darf ich das ist etwas was mich
nachhaltig beeindruckt und ja auch
natürlich beschäftigt und das geht
vielen ukraine heute habe ich damit klar
wie lange frauen ganz kurz ein fahrzeug
mit schade ich wollte so gerne wissen
warum nein du das ich wusste es
verabschieden ja das werde ich nicht
wieder fuss zu tun haben du kommst
wieder herrschinger kommt auch wieder
schönen abend noch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bild